[Music]
hello everyone my name is nori and i'm
going to be writing these one to two
minute long pieces for the keyboard i've
already started to receive requests on
what to base them on through my
instagram but the first one will just be
one that i came up with since i plan to
play them on this mini keyboard that i
have i'll generally be limiting myself
to three octaves
[Music]
but first let me give you a glimpse of
what the process of writing this was
like
so i want this to be pretty merry and
almost like a cupcake
kind of self-contained and
content
and sweet
let's see
[Music]
uh no i'm just working on some music
remember that like chinese family that
we played for so
i'm not distracted
[Music]
i need a break
[Music]
so let's switch up the rhythm
[Music]
i want it to sit more on
the c major seven chord
and then sort of roll around
[Music]
the other chord
anyway i'm going to
take a break
the form of this piece is closest to a
rondo variation at a micro perspective
the a theme keeps repeating what slide
changes every other group of two beats
when you look at the phrases for every
eight beats or so they're more like
variations from one group to the next
these aspects all add to the
merry-go-round type nature of the music
and in my opinion
even adds room for a little bit of
improvisation
and now here's the full piece
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so i hope you enjoyed that thank you so
much for watching and please share with
me any ideas or requests you have for
these little pieces subscribe if you
haven't already and i'll see you in the
next video